it's noises tender and it's absolutely  delicious marinade chilli powder paprika  coriander seeds  star anis crush thyme garlic olive oil  salt pepper mix  porkchops marinade  chill  hot pan olive oil pork chops into the  pan color on both sides tilt the pan and  baste  into the oven eight to ten minutes 200  degrees sweet potatoes peel chopped  chicken stock boil drain hot pan olive  oil shallots garlic  season lightly caramelizes slots that  helps to sweeten the potatoes up even  more sweet potatoes  crush  finish it with some fresh coriander and  sage mix  what a delicious way of eating sweet  potato pork chops out rest  sweet and delicious classic spice pork  chop with crush sweet potatoes done and  then star anis now these are beautiful  whole star anis it makes it really nice  and fragrant